here's a fraction right and they want to
turn one fraction into two fractions
right each of these fractions is kind of
like a part of this fraction which is
why later on you're going to learn what
we're about to do this technique it has
a whole name of its own because it's so
useful because each of these fractions
is a part of the original one these are
called partial fractions okay it's not
going to be immediately obvious why this
is so useful but I'll try and convince
you as we go through okay
so there won't express to this in terms
of this so these are going to be equal
and always equal right now in exactly
the same way that my approach here was
just just expand this icon right and
then see what you can compare I let me
do the same thing here I'm gonna try and
go in Reverse right if I put these two
fractions together I'm going to have a
common denominator of X plus 1 X plus 2
but that is going to change these
numerators when they come together
alright so this first guy is going to be
a X plus 2 and the second one will be
the X plus 1 are you content with that
okay I just added two fractions right
now that I've written this line I can
compare the coefficients of the
numerators right because the
denominators are identical maybe I
should just do one more step and what
you've got on the top here is a linear
function right so let's just put it into
a nice neat form that makes the
comparison of coefficients just a big
theorem
match up your x-terms I've got a plus B
and now I've got my constant terms
hanging off on the end all right let's
compare once I compare the two my a plus
B that's going to be equal to two
my two a plus B that's going to be equal
to three okay now you'll like this okay
by inspection I can see the solutions
for a and B it doesn't take very long
when you do you do an elimination here
right you go to take away one leaves you
with a equals one
right if a is equal to one then clearly
from the first equation B is also equal
to one
okay so I have my two values so now I
can go back to my very first line and
say therefore this original fraction is
made up of can be they say decomposed
decompose into these two partial
fractions right one on this plus one on
this okay so what's the big deal why did
we do this okay part of the reason why
would be clear until next time and I
will show you okay but I can tease it up
a little bit because if I gave you this
function I can't be this function I said
okay now I'm going to change the
question a little bit I want to graph
this thing and I wonder everything I
possibly can about this well we've
learnt calculus now right so a question
that's not that unreasonable is to
differentiate this thing right now when
you look at it in a commerce okay it's a
question it's a question it's not a very
nice question either
look at that messy denominator okay so
you're gonna go you be bu - - u v -
don't be squared and then you get a bit
of a disaster really okay
you can't do it's not impossible it's
just a bit long and messy but because I
have shown this
if I want to differentiate this guy
right I'm going to differentiate like
that and these are exactly the same
they're exactly the same then this is
the same as differentiating this pair of
fractions okay
now at least for the differentiation
step and for some other steps that you
will learn soon right this is much
easier much much much easier because for
both of these guys on the right-hand
side I don't have to invite them as
questions do I how else do I like these
guys oh I can write them as powers right
this is x + 1 ^ right
+ x + 2 the same deal right so now these
are both not questions but I can do
these as chain rules and be really easy
for chain rules right come on give me
the first one take the power out the
front x + 1 reduce the power by 1
derivative of the inside its 1 which is
1 so it's gonna leave it and they don't
but this guy is - x + 2 we're gonna
power down driven is he inside one so
I'm just going to leave it so I guess if
I wanted to I could just write the
fractions
look my other question okay so that was
much better and as you will see there
are even more useful things you can do
once you have partial fractions number
one often you don't have to often like
part one or question will be please do
this right and then part two we okay now
do this but secondly when you see this
and sometimes they won't tell you you
should look at this and sometimes what
they're asking you to do with this thing
is either impossible or requires
techniques that you haven't ever learned
so you need to put it into this form
because this thing you can manipulate or
you can at least manipulate it easier as
you're safe